é muito boa tarde
obrigado bem é eu estava cansado e se
toca
falando num carrinho sobre a minha
própria pessoa eu era
imagine aquele laton que há um novo
álbum desde que tinha tudo com tudo
controlado achava que a bola era só lixo
as minhas férias eram na tuga eu achava
aqui não há nada para fazer
entretanto uma coisa muito especial
aconteceu comigo eu descobri que estava
de fotografia e recorri a coisas como
vídeos e tutoriais online e comecei a
aprender a fotografar então jogou com
seriedade nos primeiros passos e comecei
a ver bem o ataque já que qualquer coisa
eu achava eu possa ser grande nas fotos
não está aqui mas nos faltou no mundo é
vitalina ainda irá concorrer a um
concurso fotográfico não conseguir nada
não é nada e voltei pra casa
completamente ocultado e conhecer bem eu
tenho que mudar isto
então foi atrás de coisas motivacionais
e encontrei uma frase que mudou
completamente a minha abordagem à
fotografia uma frase de um dom
fotográfica tem oscar sebastião salgado
mas é um grande artista eles você não
fotografa com apenas a sua máquina você
fotografa com toda a sua bagagem
cultural da paraíba então bora lá
procurar de cultura
tal eu continue as pesquisas e uma das
coisas que marcou ter encontrado foi
justamente a estudar
encontrei um lugar na internet como foi
essa coisa quando eu vi eu vi logo na
110 uma cidade abandonada onde as infra
estruturas ainda permaneceu intacta sem
mesmo assim podia ser verão areia do
deserto a consumir esses lugares
vinha de uma pista de pouso não sei se
vocês conseguem verdade no canto
esse lugar é que angola é um é uma baía
nexon amigo chamas baía dos tigres
eu pensei poxa nós temos um lugar como
esse ninguém conhece ninguém está a
explorar aquilo
isso é isso eu eu eu percebi logo a
minha fotografia tem que ser isto a
tratar lugares que eu não conheço e
muitas também não conhecem e outro
objetivo que tracei para mim próprio
tenho que conhecer o deserto
então lá fui eu comecei local no dia 10
até propôs a explorar um lugar que eu já
conhecia am superficialmente que é barra
do kuanza e pra casa ver a minha mãe que
também tem audiência palmas pra ela e
ela própria se convidou a fazer uma
coisa que eu não estava esperando
convida a fazer um passeio pelo rio
e essa oportunidade dão a chance de
fotografar coisas como aponta o pôr do
sol no na foz do rio e eu fiquei
completamente obcecado com isso tanto eu
quanto eu tenho que divulgar isso na
internet acho que tem que ver que o
barra do corda nessa aquela coisa do
passado pela ponte a cabo ledo aqui é
mais coisas pra fazer isso há foi
entretanto viveu essa experiência
divulga na internet levou uma facilmente
com excepções que também tinham as
mesmas aspirações que uma delas foi foi
um amigo meu rico mostrou o partilhou
uma fotografia de um de um barco
abandonado cemitério de naves muita
gente conhece mas na altura não conhecia
pensar como é que como assim cemitério
dos navios o barcelona e nunca vi nada
disso e portanto pronto foi unir uma
coisa à outra em traje com ruy e ele me
convidou a ir com ele ao cemitério dos
navios que lá fomos em no processo
também não vem mais uma amiga só para
garantir não poderia ser um bandido
qualquer da internet
mas pronto correu tudo bem olha é um
grande amigo meu e dos meus amigos até
foi uma experiência muito interessante
porque eu consegui sair daquele mundo
virtual com alguma vontade divulgar
alguma coisa para o real e conhecer
pessoas na internet e ver elas partilham
as mesmas aspirações que eu tinha e essa
experiência toda fez me perceber que era
uma coisa que eu precisava nós
precisamos fazer mas já não era só eu
queria fazer do penta era um grupinho de
pessoas que tenham vontade de ir a
lugares e conhecer e retratar e divulgar
então recapitulando todo esse processo
de inspiração mútua descoberta partilha
e abertura de novas possibilidades que a
cantora a uma coisa na prova acontece
quando quando as pessoas se juntam e
converte a idéia foi justamente
sustentada também pela internet não é
porque a internet é o essencial diz tudo
fez me perceber que essa era uma
processo de metamorfose
esse processo foi foi foi o processo que
mudou a minha forma de estar aqui em
angola pelo penta já não estava mais
interessado nas férias na tuga e
transformou basicamente taxa é
basicamente os meus fins de semana para
a região eram basicamente ir às bundas
ir às festas para manter no mato como
tem na aventura
eu fui com fui com os meus amigos que os
nomes que acontecer na internet com
frequência coisas muito bonitas como os
rios e cachoeiras do sumbe kwanza-sul e
fomos também a aas maravilhosas quedas
de kalandula que não podia faltar pra
casa só que também está aqui na foto aí
na audiência este nome por acaso vocês
viram ou ouviram falar dela alguns anos
atrás era também essa pessoa já vive nos
estados unidos
e pra ele te pá no canadá na bola aqui
aqui também na califórnia mas agora hoje
as coisas que deixam pô se eu não vejo a
hora de voltar para angola quero visitar
os lugares o que eu queria o x bora lá
agora fazer isso e está a fazer bons
documentários aqui vocês vão ver alguns
com mais umas coisas que vai fazer
entretanto uma das coisas que partilham
também em kalandula foi um lugar que uma
percebi que tinha visto em fotos campo
pronto vocês faz parte do processo para
pesquisar um cadeado no sobre o lugar
antes de o evitar
então um dos lugares pra casa que me
interessou foi justamente um edifício
que passa muito percebido o que estava
sujo mostrar aqui é difícil essa final
pode passar
isto é um motel à frente das quedas de
kalandula abandonado é uma extorsão já
imaginaram os bilhões de dólares
como estamos a perder porque não estamos
a investir em coisas como essas
imaginem eu voltei a kalandula foi atrás
desse lugar e com base em fotos antigas
na internet ou via como essas pessoas
viviam as férias que passavam
como é que a experiência de estar num
lugar tão perto de uma maravilha não tão
bonita como essa e não pode deixar de
também de experimentar a mesma coisa
trabalhos por acampar neste hotel e
pensamos
obrigado e pensarmos um pouco isso é uma
coisa que nós estamos a viver mas é
preciso que a nossa sociedade perceba
isso nós temos esse tipo de coisas que
angola não é só as coisas não estamos
habituados a ver que não é só os
problemas sociais que nós vivemos em
londres essa realidade porque na fachada
do anda é muito mais
tivemos mais coisas por exemplo fomos
por exemplo ao âmbito de um dos lugares
que visitamos se vê na falta à esquerda
quanto à minha esquerda
a nossa direita esta casa é a casa
abandonada de jonas savimbi
quem viveu em luanda durante os anos
sobretudo durante os anos 90
sabe a figura que jonas xavier aquela
figura que mete medo que intimida é
aliás a própria mídia fazia isso para
nós não é que nós tivemos nesse lugar
pensarmos bem nós estamos aqui e vamos
lutar pela causa do do antigo do antigo
militar como jonas savimbi no funil
vamos levar um tiro mas não foi isso que
aconteceu
as casas foram muito boa muito efetivas
e isso é uma das coisas que eu estava de
passagem mas nós pensamos que nós temos
uma idéia pré concebida como nós somos
com base em realidade porque nós as
pessoas de ambos são muito humildes são
muito receptivas e convidaram inclusiva
passear por dentro da casa ver como é
que vive a ver
verón ver a sua adega andar mais novos
vinhos verão de pronto
nós fizemos um tour aí com as pessoas em
pagar é basicamente taxas de variação
outro dos lugares que também para todos
fomos fomos nos aventurar foi essa
essa pequena bagagem está nessa barragem
do quando
há muito que estamos lá está portanto é
um lugar fantástico estar aqui
entretanto essa experiência toda terá
lugar de tevez a partilhar experiências
de inspiração mútua
vou com que outras pessoas também saber
se nesses movimentos e nos convidassem
também a participar tanto um grupo de
amigos que mora no no banco né
é também muito isso aí é um de seus
alvos
organizar um evento que era no fundo um
desafio um desafio consistia em sair nos
deslocamos do planalto central
ali no pronto no banco basicamente nos
afeta a magia no interior da huíla ali
numa zona fronteiriça entre o lubango
namibe
eu pensei bem toma convidar para ir
passear vão andar a pé vovô poder
fotografar muito mental nem reparei que
eram 16 quilômetros de caminhada que era
1 560 metros de subida e descida quando
já estava vendo o lado bom como em fibra
que achava que o mundo era pequeno o
tipo de sofrimento que passou mas pronto
é que eu estava administrar
participativo
então ver aqui do canto nós fomos este
lugar e eu caí várias vezes nós caímos
várias vezes nós nós saídos os que
saíram do andré práticas que já eram lá
já tem um certo tempo certo para o
físico então sofremos um bocadinho mas
pelo menos conseguimos viver aquela
experiência de cachorros locais vivem só
que andar longas distâncias não ter
acesso à tecnologia não ter acesso o
aluno terá acesso às coisas que nós
temos e damos por garantidas e mesmo
assim ser feliz como estamos com sol com
sobra e vimos os lugares em que eles
habitavam ficamos completamente
maravilhados com 20 e percebemos logo
imediato essas coisas têm que ser
divulgadas as que vão ser os agentes que
divulgam essas coisas
o fato de o lubango fechou a aproximar
as pessoas que lá estavam e fez me
convidam várias vezes alair e finalmente
consegui realizar um dos grandes sonhos
que eu tinha era começar a explorar na
zona do sul livre maravilhas como a
serra da leba noite
e aprenda da tundavala e de seguida
finalmente o meu sonho realizado eu
finalmente chega o deserto
eu fiquei eu conseguiu do zero eu pensei
bem e imensidão estrelas
as pessoas têm que ver essas coisas de
perto eu fiquei tão contente com essa
experiência de ir ao deserto que eu
cheguei a casa empolgado já tenha
partilhado algumas faltas acha que está
no clube e tentar chamar a soja os meus
amigos mais próximos mas nós temos que
ir outro você tem que ver as coisas que
houve então um dos meus anos dos meus
amigos aceitaram o convite e olha só a
reação deles
o som é uma parte há toda dar aquele
toque mas falando isso é aquele efeito
da pessoa chegar ao sítio que
desconhecia que não sabia que existia e
perceber que angola não é só aquela
coisa um conjunto de maravilhas um
conjunto de riquezas dos recursos
naturais da paisagem é esse sentimento
que nós que eu gostava de transmitir as
suas 22 frente passei a não ser apenas
eu mas uma comunidade inteira então diz
tudo
então toda essa toda essa todo esse
movimento toda essa energia am alguns
meses atrás foi capitalizada
no encontro que nós organizamos com o
objetivo de tirar as suas dessa
experiência virtual dá para ver a dar a
ver as coisas através de um quadradinho
no telemóvel e de facto experimentar as
coisas nós temos estado a viver e daí
aconteceu o incitamento
amo infelizmente foi meu primeiro
justamente dele infelizmente porque isso
é muito bom
foi um ambiente fantástico pula foi o
escolhido foi ótimo
acho que o direito de silenciar a
conquistar muitas coisas todas as
protege passei se beijando grafia idade
workshop e não acho que houve uma saída
caso
ela traz um dom ano base em santo andré
na volta não conhece ninguém não
conhecia ninguém tá mesmo entrando na
boca ainda para ela no grupo canibais
não podia fazer coisas nós já falamos
sobre simon johnson com um dom
sou jovem com motor era pita peço de
viajar até amigos belo anafre belo
pôr-do-sol ver nosso país tão lindo tão
lindo tão lindo tão lindo inspirando
emoções ou jovem como tu quer captar
pessoas rir viajar ser amigos de luanda
a florir ver o pôr-do-sol ver nosso país
tão lindo tão lindo tão lindo tão lindo
inspirando ilusões
muito obrigado